what's more important your name your
face or your voice one more time name
face voice what does this even really
mean let's talk about it you ever heard
the saying before I want to go make a
name for myself right and I see a lot of
times people come and say you know I
think I have to brand my name because
the world needs to know about my name
and I have a good name and everything's
around my name okay that's fine
I think the company's name is so
important if we come up with a great
company name it's gonna be this and our
name is gonna do such great things and
I'm the complete opposite school of
thought I just had a meeting one of my
good friends from high school I used to
work with him at Burger King many many
many many years ago good friend of mine
and we were sitting down he's pursuant
the business of Hollywood entertainment
and I said the formula is the same
formula unless if your name is let's
just say your last name is Vanderbilt
and you are from that lineage let's just
say your last name is Kennedy and you
are from that lineage let's you say your
last name is Reagan you're from that
lineage let's just say it's Sheen yet
cirshades Manning let's just say it's
griffey or or the Jackson family if your
name is from that last name and you're
related to that last time you have an
edge on everybody else because you get
to use your contact and you have access
to the resources of the attorneys the
CPAs the accountants the agents the
managers the producers the directors the
politicians the senator the governor and
that can give you an edge on somebody
else who doesn't have those resources to
start off with but what if your name
doesn't have that lineage so let's look
at another one unless if you look like
Pamela Anderson and Pamela Anderson the
way she was figured out she was in
Canada at a football game boom her
picture gets on a Jumbotron some agent
likes her picks her up next thing you
know now she's Pamela Anderson Baywatch
all these other things that she's done
you know what if you don't look like
Pamela Anderson what if you don't look
like Adriana Lima from Victoria's Secret
or Naomi Campbell Cindy Crawford
Stephanie Seymour Kate Moss Claudia
Schiffer Christie Brinkley Brad Pitt
Matthew McConaughey any of these names
what if you don't look like them what if
just you're just an average looking guy
or girl what if you don't have that skin
that body that height that you know look
that smile that charm that dimple what
if you don't look like that so then what
do you do
someone's gonna say why I wish I
like that person I wish I had that
person's body that's when it comes to
the last one and the last one is
something everybody can do let me
explain to what I mean by the last one
the last one is voice your voice not
sinking voice your voice for instance
Lincoln was a nobody he grows up in a
small place no one knows who he is
he keeps bringing value to the world and
eventually he has a voice and then
eventually he runs and becomes one the
greatest some Saidi greatest president
of all time because he worked on his
voice you know what if you are Seneca
you you'reyou're the founder of stoicism
and you come out and you start talking
about stoicism you're teaching stoicism
and then all of a sudden Marcus Aurelius
picks up your content and he starts
teaching stoicism then his voice voice
based on a value that you're bringing to
the world
Einstein your voice you come out with
EMS equals mc-squared everybody follows
it how about salman khan khanacademy all
he wants to do is show math and show all
these formulas and kids are looking at
him as an online tutor and next thing
you know he becomes who he becomes a
Robert Greene the author of forty laws
of power who is the modern-day played
over Socrates because he's teaching the
way he's teaching so if if you spend
more time focusing on the value you're
providing to the world more on the value
you're increasing to the world and the
results you bring into the world
eventually people will know your face
and eventually you will make a name for
yourself but I suggest you focus more on
providing value to know having a big
voice and eventually from a small
community maybe you only have 17
subscribers on YouTube you only have 20
fans on Facebook that's fine brings
value to your 17 subscribers bring value
to your 20 fans your 300 friends your
500 friends whatever community you're on
and all of a sudden people will pick up
if you're continues to bring in value
people will constantly say every time I
listen to her I learn something new
every time I listen to him I feel better
every time I listen to him I get more
clear about my fitness my health
entrepreneurship business whatever your
mo is but it's gotta be based on
increasing value you watch the last 100
videos I'll put up you'll never see me
starting a video on my name you know why
cuz my main name means nothing to you my
name is nothing to you my name is a lot
to me
my name is a lot to my family well my
name is nothing to you however some of
you may watch the video you may say who
is this guy let me go look up who is
Patrick wait David then you research
Patrick but David then you recognize the
face but you don't know the name or the
face unless if you see the value that
I'm providing to you that you'll learn
from and that becomes a voice that you
share with others then it increases the
name my suggestion to you is find ways
to increase the value you're bringing to
other people by reading learning being
curious absolutely
immersing yourself in a subject that you
are so curious about and next thing you
know you're following will increase and
it'll become a community thing friends
family state country international then
everybody knows who you are with the
value you're providing to the world
that's my message to embody if you have
any questions on a what I talked about
today can tweet me at Patrick made David
post a question on the bottom and if you
haven't subscribed to the channel on
YouTube Value table please be sure to do
so thanks for watching